do i have it right baseball is opening
up again
i guess there's a a little bit of a
pre-season and then we go into the
season the shortened season yeah
john i heard you were upset that you
could have your own cardboard cutout
sitting at the game
which is really kind of you know you
turn on the game
and you just see these cardboard cutouts
sitting behind the plate
it's a bad look you know it's like we
know the stadiums are empty
there's no reason to be putting cutouts
of dogs and cats
or a likeness of yourself there to
pretend
like the fans are there the cool thing
they're doing though
is they're pumping out in crowd noise
yeah and they're doing them you think
that's
cool well they're cause they're doing a
really good job of it
that one's driven to left field and deep
going back suspended as he's on the
track he's at the wall see ya
it's sort of like white noise in the
background and it seems to work but the
cardboard cutouts just
they look so ridiculous yeah but maybe i
mean i've seen
what it looks like with an empty stadium
maybe psychologically the cardboard
cutout maybe it gives it some energy
just like the the fake sound effects and
stuff but what i'm thinking is
see these baseball players like you're
sitting in a basement
right they're playing in an empty field
with nobody to cheer for them the player
is robbing i mean the dugouts
they're all spaced out they're wearing
masks in the dugouts some of the players
are wearing actually masks on the field
and the umpires are scared too because
they're out there and some of masks and
some don't
and if a player gets covered then
you know they're out for a good two
weeks and they need to
run two tests before positive tests
before they can come back
so with the seasons what about the other
players who were around him does
everybody have to get tested again
exactly no they have to get tested every
day so so the season
is a 60 game season 6-0 so if somebody
gets sick
and it runs through the team you're
screwed i mean your season is basically
over and a really interesting thing in
canada
they refuse to let the toronto blue jays
play in their stadium because of the
covid threat so they're going to be
playing their season
in pittsburgh which is wow i haven't
seen you this worked up since they cut
the mcdonald's menu in half
you know what i mean when they
simplified
you